d'abord je vais m'associer
aux propos du président vous souhaitant
la bienvenue
pour un ministre dans la continuité de
son action bruno le maire et à gabriel
attal également bienvenue donc dans
notre assemblée dont vous savez quel là
pour habitude de travailler avec sérieux
mais également avec une grande vigilance
et nous poursuivrons en nous mettant
comme vous rapidement au travail puisque
nous disposons le président l'a rappelé
enfin des éléments que nous attendions
depuis un long moment mais j'ai compris
que la première ministre
et ré à améliorer
modifier les habitudes d'hier donc vous
serez je pense messieurs les ministres
toujours les bienvenus dans cette maison
je voulais faire quelques quelques
observations d'abord une première sur
l' hypothèse d'inflation que vous avez
retenu qui est qui est la vôtre c'est le
scénario central 5% pour l'année 2022 là
où l'insee prévoit l 5 6%
qu'est ce qui a motivé
ce de retenir ce choix qui est surtout
qu'elle
quel serait le coût de ce différentiel
pour nos finances publiques dont je me
plais à entendre mais j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir dans quelques instants
l'attachement au redressement des
comptes monsieur le ministre bruno le
maire que vous avez rappelé donc le coût
de ce différentiel notamment par les
effets sur les obligations indexées ou
bien encore les mesures de soutien aux
ménages puisque on a bien compris que
tout ça n'était pas neutre
deuxième observation
vous l'indiquez et vous le répéter à
l'envi depuis quelque temps un peu en
forme d'aveu la cote d'alerté est
atteinte pour les finances publiques
si je comprends bien lorsqu'elle est
atteinte elle est même dépassée et
j'ai bien entendu vos propos hier devant
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée vous avez affirmé la
nécessité de compter chaque euro dans
les temps actuels et qu'il nous fallait
donc tenir compte du fait évidemment que
les conditions de financement ont changé
mais avez vous monsieur le ministre
réellement le sentiment que ce plfr
traduit vos propos je vais je vais
m'appuyer sur un exemple le plfr ouvre
des crédits nouveaux sur une centaine de
programmes du budget général pour un
total de plus de 47 milliards en montant
brut et non annuler que sur un seul
programme celui de l'évaluation de la
charge d'intérêts de sncf réseau pour 9
millions d'euros alors
certes il s'agit aussi pour vous de
rétablir les crédits annulés dans le
cadre du décret d'avancé pour financer
la remise de 18 centimes en avril
dernier mais cela signifie t'il aussi
que vous n'avez pas pu identifier un
seul programme du budget général en
dehors des crédits apéritif que je viens
de mentionner sur lesquels les crédits
aurait pu être annulé de manière à
compenser et au moins partiellement les
ouvertures de crédits nécessaires sur
d'autres dispositifs
12 milliards
sont prévus pour les participations
financières de l'état
or la première ministre dans sa
déclaration de politique générale a
annoncé l'intention de l'état de détenir
100% du capital d'edf là encore hier
vous avez indiqué devant nos collègues
députés que les 12 milliards d'euros
correspondait à l'acquisition des
actions manquantes d'edf ainsi qu'à
d'éventuelles d'autres opérations quel
est donc concrètement le montant qui est
prévu pour l'opération lie à edf et
selon quels critères des participations
financières sur est elle envisagée pour
d'autres opérations
je voudrais abl évoqué également le dans
ce plfr la suppression confirmée dès
2022 de la contribution à l'audiovisuel
le public
vous la présenter comme une mesure de
pouvoir d'achat je dirais c'est relatif
puisque si on regarde le gard elles pour
les ménages concernés je rappelle que
près de 5 millions de foyers sont d'ores
et déjà exonérés du paiement de cette
contribution
une suppression qui était d'ailleurs
largement anticipé mais qui souffre de
manques et de carence puisque le
gouvernement s'était engagé en 2019 a
présenté un rapport sur l'avenir de ce
prélèvement devant le parlement
le document n'a jamais été publiée en
octobre de l'an dernier une mission
conjointe inspection des finances
et inspection générale des affaires
culturelles devait rendre des
conclusions absence complète
vous parlez de transparence c'est mieux
de travailler effectivement en bonne
intelligence et en donnant les chiffres
r les mettant à la connaissance de nos
aux assemblées donc j'ai le sentiment
sur ce sujet d'être plutôt dans une
politique du fait accompli alors je vous
reconnais au moins le courage de vous
attaquer une modernisation du secteur de
l'audiovisuel public
ce qu'il faut savoir maintenant c'est
comment allez vous procéder pour 2023
gmail un peu plus loin je pense que
plutôt que de supprimer sans donner de
je dirais les ressources sont donnés de
choix alternatifs
il eût été préférable
peut-être d'y aller progressivement
justement en travaillant en partage avec
les deux assemblées
cinquième et dernier point à ce stade
4 milliards 6 sont proposées dans ce
projet de loi de finances pour la mise
en place d'un dispositif de soutien aux
travailleurs qui dispose d'un véhicule
c'est un peu ses pattes a fait la moitié
2 milliards et puis la prolongation de
la remise sur le prix des carburants à
la pompe 2 milliards 6 dans le dossier
de presse on a des indications qui sont
plus précises et vous les avez évoqué
rapidement sur le ciblage notamment
et personnes qui roulent beaucoup et qui
sont des personnes actives ça c'est pour
remplacer la remise actuelle et pour
laquelle deux milliards sont fléchés
mais j'ai entendu donc vous allez
certainement nous donner d'autres
précisions il semblerait qu'il ne soit
pas les seuls les actifs ont bénéficié
puisque j'avais parlé d'un certain
nombre de professions vous avez pas de
profession noms de personnes qui
notamment les retraités qui évidemment
lorsqu'il roule encore et ne sont dans
des territoires où en plus n'ont pas de
choix alternatifs
vous indiquez
depuis hier que les parlementaires
pourront faire près part de leur volonté
et essayer de fixer vous l'avez encore
évoqué il ya quelques instants le
curseur pour les rouleurs entre
guillemets concernés et le montant qui
pourrait correspondre à chaque niveau
mais il ya il ya une question c'est dans
quelle mesure dès lors que le projet de
loi ne prévoit pas de dispositif en dur
et uniquement des crédits budgétaires
puisque vous savez quand même que nous
sommes contraints par la recevabilité
financière de nos amendements donc la
question c'est de quelle marge de
manoeuvre si ce n'est en dehors d'une
forme de bavardage qui pourrait être un
peu intempestifs à contretemps disposons
nous vraiment raison pour laquelle je
m'interroge sur la capacité de dialogue
et les ouvertures auquel vous êtes
disposé messieurs les ministres
merci monsieur le rapporteur général
alors je vous indique avant de donner la
parole au ministre pour les premières
réponses au rapporteur général que j'ai
neuf inscrits 10 je n'irai pas plus loin
merci
donc dix inscrits donc les fissures ont
à peu près une minute trente alors
essayé essayé d'être est d'être dans la
synthèse le plus possible et dans la
question je vous rappelle que nous
posons des questions
merci monsieur le monsieur mais j'essaie
de respecter le temps d un des uns et
des autres monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président merci se
rapportant général pour vos questions et
très heureux de continuer aussi
avec vous pour les années qui viennent
cinq questions j'apporterai quatre
réponses et gabriel vous répondra sur la
contribution à l'audiovisuel public
l'hypothèse l'inflation nous avons
retenu est une hypothèse effectivement à
5% celles de l'insee à 5,6 tout
simplement parce que nous avons une
évaluation différente sur le prix du
baril l'insee air au prix hypothèse 120
dollars le baril nous une hypothèse 114
dollars le baril je rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui le baril est à 108
dollars donc nous sommes légèrement au
dessus du cours du marché
nous continuerons à suivre ça de près
mais je pense que notre hypothèse
aujourd'hui est raisonnable et
correspond à la situation du marché
s'agissant de la charge de la dette
c'est la raison principale pour laquelle
j'ai dit que nous avons atteint la côte
d'alerté
je revendique le quoi qu'il en coûte
nous a permis d'éviter un dérapage de la
dette parce que indemniser des
entreprises et à indemniser les chômeurs
c'est plus coûteux que de les protéger
avant en revanche nous avons mis en
place quoi qu'il en coûte avec des taux
d'intérêt à zéro
voire négatif
les situations ayant radicalement changé
et une partie de la dette française
étant comme vous l'avez rappelé indexées
sur l'inflation nous ne pouvons plus
continuer comme cela ça n'est pas
possible ce serait pas responsable dans
l'est de cesse de le rappeler un point
d'inflexion en plus c'est de venir de 5
milliards d'euros de charge la dette
supplémentaire en raison de l'indexation
d'une partie notre dette 10 %
précisément sur l'inflation et je
rappelle que dans cette partie de la
dette indexée sur l'inflation et deux
tiers sont indexés sur le niveau
d'inflation moyen la zone euro qui est
très supérieur aux niveaux d'inflation
de la france c'est ce qui nous amène à
inscrire 12 milliards d'euros de charge
la dette supplémentaire en raison de
l'inflation donc ça doit nous amener
effectivement comme vous l'avez rappelé
à faire preuve de beaucoup de sens des
responsabilités
sur les économies je partage ce que vous
dite je pense qu'il est important au
delà de la première réponse pourrait
table des finances publiques qui le
plein emploi quelle réponse de loin la
plus efficace qui suppose qui suppose
des décisions structurelles réforme des
retraites assurance chômage mais qui
suppose aussi des dépenses à réduire et
je donne rendez-vous pour le plf 2010 23
je pense qu'il est important que dans ce
travail collectif que nous ouvrons sur
la méthode qui a défini la première
ministre nous puissions travailler tous
ensemble à identifier les gisements de
dépenses publiques qui pourrait être
réduite dans les années qui viennent et
nous permettent de tenir notre
engagement de 3% de déficit je le redis
cette trajectoire doit être tenu elles
vont être tenues pour notre indépendance
nationale il ne peut être tenu que s'il
n'y a pas de dérapage en 2022 et que si
nous arrivons à créer le plein emploi
dans notre pays a engagé des réformes de
structure et à identifier effectivement
un certain nombre de dépenses a réduit
s'agissant des participations de l'état
c'est la seule réponse sur laquelle j'ai
peur de vous décevoir parce que je ne
peux pas donner que c'est une opération
qui est en cours préciser exactement le
montant qui sera consacré à la
nationalisation d'edf dans ces 12 et 2 7
milliards d'euros
qu'ils comprennent la nationalisation
d'edf et d'autres opérations sur les
titres de l'état qui pourrait être
nécessaire dans le courant de l'année en
fonction de l'évolution de la situation
économique à son entreprise que nous
n'avons pas laissé tomber depuis le
début de la crise et que nous ne
laisserons jamais tomber
enfin sur le soutien aux travailleurs je
redis que des paramètres peuvent être
discutées dès aujourd'hui pour améliorer
le dispositif
pour être tout à fait précis je redis
qu'il est réservé aux personnes qui
travaillent que soient indépendants
salariés fonctionnaires alternant pour
être tout à fait précis pour les déciles
1 2 et 3 ce sera une aide de 200 euros
pour les déciles 4 et 5 une aide de 100
euros avec une majoration de 50% si
jamais votre
lieu de travail et patrick normand
éloigné de votre domicile est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin sur les déciles ou
moins loin en concentrant les forts ça
je trouve que c'est un débat qui est
particulièrement utile et nous pourrons
je vous le confirme améliorer ensemble
ce dispositif enfin sur les retraités
c'est un choix politique et nous avons
indexer les retraites nous les
augmentons de 4% et nous concentrons
l'effort sur les déplacements sur les
personnes qui travaillent soient bons
choix politique peut être discutée mais
c'est le choix que nous proposons aux
parlementaires
[Musique]